BIRT King Reynolds who else could keep
this town runnin video game cameos are a
joy to witness some brilliantly cast the
right character to play the right here
or the right villain but sometimes they
stand out like a sore thumb and make you
gasp for air in this list we'll be
looking at five celebrity cameos that
made a stop and thank our lucky stars we
were alive to see it
or in other words here are five random
celebrity cameos you need to see
on a sidenote a politician in our eyes
is not a celebrity so don't expect a
good old Barry to show up in mercs to
all that time NBA Jam became political
face off or even Donald Trump showing up
in surgeon simulator that doesn't count
in this list
Phil Collins may look like a geography
teacher but in fact he's the greatest
drummer you will ever meet even Harambee
is a foul
in PSP classic bike City Stories Phil
Collins who has wanted part of Genesis
the band not the Sega console pops up
regularly in the game and even gives us
a slightly terrible rendition of I can
feel it coming in the air tonight
that's an off bill leave it to her amber
let's stick with the 80s for our next
installment and it's Michael Jackson the
King of Pop shows up and ready to rumble
boxing ele waiting to be the living
daylights out of his opponents his
signature dress sense and white sequined
glove is accurately portrayed and he
doesn't hold his punches if I was going
up against the King of Pop I was
throwing the towel or maybe a blanket
since Roy has a slew of celebrity cameos
but our favorite is WWE Superstar rowdy
roddy piper showing up in center or for
spotting his famous kilt and hot rod
t-shirt and with the eerie sounds of
bagpipes playing in the background Piper
is on hand to help you beat up a man
named Keith if you haven't played any
central games this one is a bizarre tale
where you play the President of the USA
inside a nightmare so let's move on do
you know what time traveling robot the
Terminator does when he isn't murdering
the Connor family
well his favorite pastime is wrestling
in the WWE in 2k16 you can indeed pick a
knee and he will make his way to the
ring wearing his t1 or t2 costume even
the theme tune from the film's will play
as he enters the ring
the following contest is scheduled to
stop making his way to the ring from the
year 2000
he's an absolute beast
how does he celebrate his victory by
staring and looking samba he also looks
a little like he needs to visit the
restroom as soon as possible we've
reached the top of our list and it comes
from postal to Gary Coleman was a star
of Diff'rent Strokes in the 70s and 80s
and I know most of you won't have a clue
where that is and we'll be thinking
which dog about stamp would you don't
monkey what you talking about Willis
what you talking about lady you might
need to ask your mom and dad about that
Coleman was best known for playing a
young boy but became famous in his own
right through reality TV and an infamous
John Cena rap video which you have to
search for now it's brilliantly whilst
playing fossil 2 you can indeed go visit
Gary Coleman who's at a book signing
session you could line up and whip your
turn to meet the great actor or you
could do what eat my addiction one did I
found them Gary Gary Gary ma'am
I'm trying to have a little one-on-one
time with Gary Gary
don't make me do this Gary
goodnight sweet tidy prints so that's
our list of five random celebrity cameos
you have to see I'm sure there are
hundreds I've missed so please sound off
below and let me know thanks for
watching and please press subscribe to
help us reach more people I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time